[Music]
hey folks welcome to the dark horse
podcast live stream number 130 did i get
it it's 130 which is
it's not even worth checking not prime
this is brett weinstein dr brett
weinstein dr heather heing at your
service we are here going to sort
through uh many a thing is what i'm
imagining yep we're coming to you
earlier this week uh brett and our
younger son have a plane to catch
so um
so here we are we're not gonna do a q a
this week
we are going to start with announcements
before launching into a discussion of
some of what's going on in portland some
of what's going on in the lgbtq
community possibly given its pride month
and uh and brett is going to uh do a
sort of a larger level analysis as is
your want as is something that i say and
always wonder what exactly it means when
i say it
i think it means that i want to do it
although you're going to tell me it's
spelled differently it's spelled
differently it's not the same thing well
no we know we've and we've had that
conversation too so you know
these last two years or very groundhog
day in some ways yeah yeah there's been
a lot of that there's been a lot of that
it's been a lot of that yeah so um we
actually had a lot of fun this week um
believe it or not we had a lot of fun
this week doing many many hours almost
10 hours of
interviews for the spanish language
edition of hunter-gatherer's guide which
we don't have a copy of yet so i can't i
can't show it to you but it's out it's
published
and
there's about to be a lot of media
coverage in spain and in spanish
language newspapers uh wherever wherever
those are available you can hold up the
french one and the people who are
listening on audio only wouldn't know
the difference that's true that's true
that's true and i i forgot to pull up um
what it is in spanish and even though my
spanish pronunciation isn't perfect i'd
be perfectly happy to say it but i don't
remember offhand um but anyway the um
the journalists were fantastic uh we had
a translator because our spanish is
unfortunately not even close to good
enough to to do these things in spanish
the translator who was working with us
on behalf of the spanish publisher was
outstanding uh it was just it was it was
a lens into
uh spanish culture and spain is not a
place that either of us have been we
spent a lot of time in latin america but
never been to spain and it was it was
truly remarkable yes and the interviews
uh were
seen pillow in la lengua
that's the spanish idiom for it means no
hair on the tongue but it means
straightforward direct i think otherwise
i've said something lewd but
i believe that's how you say uh that
they were directed to the point we will
find out in the comments almost
immediately okay
okay i'm not sure i so i didn't i don't
know if that idiom is correct i didn't
know it if it is and i'm not sure i
would describe the interviews that way
if it is so i'm sort of i'm three stages
deep of not being sure how to proceed
can we agree that the interviews were
monos in
la cabeza i don't know why you're doing
this i don't know just gonna come off
sounding like complete idiots no i don't
think so without monkeys in the head
monkey's on the brain sure
brain is different but okay
it's close enough
people are very generous when you try to
speak their language in earnest that's
been my experience it's true but it's
rather different when you're actually
speaking to a mostly english-speaking
audience in
half-assed spanish
well i was hoping they'd be impressed
now i think they're likely not to be but
and that's on me
no you know an effort was made whatever
it was made all right um
yeah so that was um that was great and
uh yes we've been hearing from a lot of
people who've been waiting for the
spanish language edition in particular
and it's it's out now so you can find
that
most places that books are sold in
spanish including amazon
yes uh so as i said we're not did i say
we're not doing a q a this week yes um
and uh we are live on youtube and
odyssey right now i believe
uh the chat is live on odyssey uh we
have a cool new shirt coming to our
store.darkhorsepodcast.org
next week i believe but right now you
can still go get things like epic
tabbies and
uh and digital book burning and
and such i am confident enough on this
new shirt that i think we can fairly
guarantee that they will love it all
right you know all of them
pretty much
you can't miss all right yeah all right
it's okay it feels a little niche to me
i don't think it'll
outrage anyone right right i mean
you know a small number of people may be
indifferent but i think
i feel good about it okay excellent well
that'll that will bring to you next week
and we'll be back at our regular time
next week
one more teaser for next week as long as
we're teasing next week's next week's
broadcast um next week i believe i'm
going to try to explain why everything
is labeled in the inverse
why the disinformation is really
informative and the information is
labeled this information um
it's begun to come together and i'm
going to lay out a model next week so
anyway uh hopefully people will
tune in for that and we'll see what they
think
yeah so i'm just putting that writing it
down so you remember that it's actually
yes
i didn't know that um
all right dropping things on me as we
are live here okay
um
we
uh as always we encourage you to go to
natural selections which is uh where i
write on substack
almost everything is available there for
free although i did post a short thing
there this week for paying subscribers
only that i called uh maybe you don't
need enemies prompted by my observations
walking around
parts of portland
noticing as i have in traveling many
parts of the world in the past how easy
it is to reach people if you actually
just
change your face from totally neutral or
worse to a smile
and
it is remarkable how many people don't
do that and so immediately start
interactions that maybe they'll never
have with another person again
with a with a neutral or worse
expectation and it's rather easy to
change that and
people are even more hungry for
niceness and human connection than ever
right now so
uh anyway that's on that's my natural
selection is now you were going to add
something no i was just going to say
that yes the the fear that has been used
to
corral us and direct us is obviously
contagious in a way that uh yeah um has
been demonstrated to be true of many
emotional states so yeah your your your
point about breaking that circuit by
broadcasting something else which is
also contagious um i i agree that's a
and this key this is a this excuse me is
a theme that will come up a little bit
later on as we talk today but also i
think we should probably come back to it
in longer form later the
the contagion of emotions uh that is
well understood in many circles and that
is being weaponized
and therefore used to create great
greater tribal divisions between us and
than we would otherwise have
is
is stark and the fact that you know we
can pretty much all see that it happens
online where we're not really engaging
with the complete human being even if
we're engaging with someone who we know
to be a real human being the online
existence is not
is is not their entire human beingness
and when we're actually engaging with
another human being out in the world
even if it's someone we don't know
very often we go into it assuming this
isn't going to work
there's nothing to be done there i
already know that the boundaries are
drawn and this is unlikely to be a
person i can talk to and
by and large that's not true
yeah um it's interesting that you remove
let's put it this way
it almost never happens that people
break each other's noses but the risk
that it could happen actually sets
bounds in the in-person interaction that
um
cause most of those interactions to be a
great deal better if you just simply
lean into them
um yeah this is interesting this is
going to be a place where men and women
have very different traditional ways of
of interacting and of uh you know what
you know how things can escalate when
they go bad and therefore what the
threats are underneath things and you
know it's it's very rare that in all
female spaces noses and end up broken
but that's not to say that
that
terrifically bad things don't happen as
a result of what can happen in those
spaces
but they tend to happen via very
different routes and i think part of
as i've talked about before as we've
talked about before part of the
confusion of modernity
is
pretending that men and women aren't
different pretending
in some circuit in some
places imagining that going back to
traditional roles would be the solution
no like can't happen and no thank you
uh pretending that the only way out of
it or imagine the only way out of it is
imagining that we're the same and
therefore there's nothing to be
negotiated no have you met people
obviously that's not true
but
knowing that we are different and we
will never be the same and that
traditional roles
are
full of now outdated stereotypes and
some of them were always outdated or
were never relevant is what i mean
uh means that we need to forge a way
forward while recognizing that on
average an all male group will end up
negotiating differences and mediating
a conversation and decision-making
differently from how an all-female group
will and therefore when as in modernity
we have male and female groups together
moving forward with decision making and
team building and problem solving it is
very likely that we need to be explicit
and careful about recognizing that just
defaulting to either male typical or
female typical mode is not going to be
successful
so actually um as long as we're here
yeah it occurs to me that we have a
story that um illustrates the problem of
the environment that takes the broken
nose off the table okay
so
for those of you listening at home stop
me if i've told you this before but we
have a friend named george i won't give
his last name who is a fellow cyclist
who was cycling along one day
and because those in vehicles
have very little risk from those on
bicycles there's a fair amount of weird
stuff that gets directed at us sometimes
i've been hit by a bb
once um people yell things they'll honk
trying to scare you to fall off your
bicycle or whatever
george was cycling along and a woman on
a cycle uh gets um a subset of things
that men don't get as well which is you
know obnoxious and you know has an
additional level of threat because
obviously someone in a vehicle uh can
catch up to someone on a bicycle unless
you've got access to trails or thin
alleys and it's useful to have those
anyway yes uh cat calls from some really
uncool cats
beyond catcall sometimes yeah yeah
anyway george not a woman uh was never
been never identified as such actually
we have not checked in with george don't
know how it's gone but as far as we know
still a guy
i'd love some money on that yeah i would
too anyway he was cycling along minding
his own business and uh
some dudes in a truck um
pulled up behind him he was not noticing
them and one of them hurled a half full
beer can at him and hit him
and they shouted something out the
window and sped off george was enraged
as one might be
and he rode like crazy and the dudes in
the truck got caught at a stoplight
several blocks away and did not realize
that george was gaining on them
george pulled up to the stoplight
grabbed the guy who had thrown the beer
cam through the window pulled him
through the window and broke his nose
and said
don't [ __ ] with bicyclists and i would
imagine that that guy has stopped
[ __ ] with bicyclists
so
or gone the opposite direction no i'm
pretty sure george made his point um you
know broken nose that that gives you
time to think yeah so anyway my thought
is that the car interaction you are
there in person but the advantage that
the driver and the passenger have over
the cyclist makes it more like twitter
but in this particular case
george's excellent cycling and the
luck of the stop stoplight having
brought those fellows to a halt
uh turned the tables and there's
literally a power differential
um
yes they're
scary i was trying to make a pun power
differential yeah yeah i'm going to
diagram that later and figure out what
it was and then i'll how the vehicle has
a differential yeah bicycle doesn't
true yeah quite right quite right um
anyway but i think the
um
anyway the point is the risks in the
situation set the rules i've made the
point
uh in an article i wrote for unheard
that actually firing ranges
and gun shops tend to be very polite
places because
presumably there are a lot of people uh
possessed a firearm so anyway this is an
interesting question you know polite and
in my very limited experience friendly
yeah welcoming
very welcoming
all right well
all right so
we were talking i don't remember how we
got on that on that topic oh my my sub
stack this week maybe you don't need
enemies maybe maybe you can drop the
idea that everyone is
um likely to be your enemy out there and
walk around being more welcoming and
have just a better time of it when
you're out there in the world
and
uh and then i just wanted to say before
we do our sponsors for the week many of
you are supporting us many ways by
subscribing to the channel on youtube on
odyssey both the main channel and the
dark horse podcast clips channels
you are liking videos who are sharing
videos which is the the way that word
spreads so if you are if you are valuing
what we do
uh please do that please share with with
family and friends and hopefully that
doesn't get you um unfamiliar and
unfriended
and
for those of you who can uh we of course
appreciate financial contributions we
were demonetized by youtube last summer
and that has that has never come back
but we do have a revenue that comes in
through our patreons we thank all the
the patrons for supporting us that way
and
i have something to say about the
discord that's available on our
patreon but i have
i have lost it once again there it is
our wonderful discard community where
you can engage in honest conversations
about difficult topics join a book club
even unwind with virtual happy hours and
they've had a lot of them
and even karaoke young or old left or
right
there's a spot for you around the
campfire so you can access that through
our patreons there's also a monthly
keyword private q a brett has
conversations through his patreons once
a month
and
we also have sponsors
three the top of the hour
we will begin those now
our first sponsor this week is seed
seed is a company focused on bacteria
and the microbiome and has a terrific
probiotic called ds01 daily symbiotic
there are so many actions that you can
take to enhance your health
our sign off here at darkhorse includes
three of them be good to the ones you
love eat good food and get outside but a
lot is hidden in those words what for
instance constitutes good food good food
is real food whole food food that has
been alive recently and was grown with
care and conditions as ancient as
possible given the constraints of the
21st century a point to which we'll
return in our third sponsor for this
week but even many people who eat such a
diet can be missing something
we contain multitudes every individual
human contains so many other organisms
some of which may harm us but many of
which exist with us in harmony we need
them this is why probiotics can be an
important tool in a healthy lifestyle
even if you eat nutrient dense food and
avoid processed foods and sugar as we
all should be doing
that said probiotics are in some ways
the new current thing ever heard of
probiotic tortilla chips for instance
they were a thing and no they're not
going to be effective good news though
seeds ds01 daily symbiotic is the real
deal
not all probiotics are created equal
seeds ds01 daily symbiotics of broad
spectrum two in one probiotic and
prebiotic it contains a proprietary
formulation of 24 distinct probiotic
strains in scientifically studied
dosages in a two in one capsule that
protects the probiotics until they hit
the colon where they are most effective
if you've taken a probiotic for and
never felt a difference it's likely
because the good bacteria weren't
surviving your gi tract seed is designed
differently and that's why it works
seeds daily symbiotic supports gut
health including maintenance of the gut
barrier as well as skin and heart health
and micronutrient synthesis many have
used c to report improvements to the to
their digestive function in 24 to 48
hours
so start a new healthy habit today visit
seed.com darkhorse and use code
darkhorse to redeem 20 off your first
month of seeds ds01 daily symbiotic
that's seed.com darkhorse news code
darkhorse
our second sponsor for the day is
mudwater
which is a coffee alternative made with
mushrooms herbs and spices
with one-seventh the caffeine is a cup
of coffee you get energy without the
anxiety jitters or crash that many who
drink coffee experience
each ingredient in mud water was added
with intention it's got cacao and chai
lion's mane cordyceps chaga and reishi
turmeric and cinnamon among other
ingredients
and this is really a terrific product
either on its own or as a warm drink in
the morning
black or with cream or honey there's
definitely a hint of chocolate in the
flavor and the masala chai blend
includes ginger and cardamom nutmeg and
cloves and lately i've been blending it
into a smoothie with a banana and ice
some delicious locally made entirely nut
milk mint and cacao nibs it's totally
delicious
they also now have an evening blend with
no caffeine at all
that's terrific as a as a before sleep
drink
mud water is 100 usda organic non-gmo
gluten free vegan and kosher certified
furthermore they donate a percentage of
revenue to the multidisciplinary
association for psychedelic studies and
work with pachama to contribute to
reforestation efforts
mudwater allows you to build a morning
ritual that promotes sustained energy
without the crash
visit mudwater.com darkhorse to support
the show and use darkhorse at checkout
for fifteen percent off that's
m-u-d-w-t-r dot com slash darkhorse use
darkhorse at checkout for fifteen
percent off
and our final sponsor this week is moiq
that's moo plus oink an eighth
generation farmer founded moic and is
working hard to help save the family
farm and get its customers access to the
highest quality meat on earth whereas 97
of the chickens served in the us are
dipped in chlorine family farms don't
tend to do that moique delivers
grass-fed grass-finished beef and lamb
pastured pork and chicken and
wild-caught alaskan salmon direct to
your door like farmers farm like your
grandparents did and as a result moink
meat tastes like it should which is to
say delicious unlike the supermarket
moink gives you total control over the
quality and source of your food you
choose the meat delivered in every box
like rib eyes and chicken breasts pork
chops and salmon fillets and much more
plus you can cancel any time we love
everything about moic the fact that the
meat is grass-fed and finished on small
farms the lovely publications that come
along with it and of course the meat
itself
shark tank host kevin o'leary called
moiq bacon the best bacon he has ever
tasted we agree it's amazing
keep american farming going
by signing up at mointbox.com darkhorse
right now and listeners of this show
will receive a free filet mignon for a
year
that's one year of the best filet mignon
you ever taste but for a limited time
that's moinkbox.com
m-o-i-n-k-b-o-x dot com slash dark horse
all right
all right
we are going to start uh by sharing a
few photos that i took yesterday while
walking around north portland
zach i think uh you should have them you
want to put the first one up
so
i was in a really a lovely shop
that had
among one of the very few unlovely
things
a
this for people just listening some pins
which have on the left vaxxed i'm
vaccinated
and on the right pronoun pins
and to me this
reminded me
of
the cultural moment we are living in
which has people who are confused about
what sex is
and who are insisting
that however you feel like identifying
is the sex that you are and therefore
it's paramount and maybe the most
important thing about you to announce
your pronouns in your bios and in
introducing yourself to other people and
enforcing that on
uh all all the people in your world
well it's many of the same people who
are certain
that although 500 million years of
evolution might be wrong the authorities
that just came to you dressed in lab
coats couldn't possibly be and therefore
the new experimental technologies that
everyone is being told they absolutely
must take is the only way forward
did you want to add something
yeah
i wanted to introduce
i wondered
and this is completely inconsistent with
where you're headed here
when you see a consensus
and you also see coercion you see people
who depart from the consensus being
punished
and you therefore know that some
percentage of the consensus is the
result of people who fear saying
otherwise and that
what uh might be
objections or diversity of opinion shows
up as silence
the question is why does the mind
not register that that consensus isn't
one or i think even more likely at the
point you see intense coercion in the
direction of a consensus one ought to
think that consensus is probably wrong
it wouldn't be necessary if the
consensus were right it would be
naturally contagious this is a point
that neil oliver was making in your
conversation with him that you that you
had as well yes so yes but
does this fallacy have a name where you
fail to register you've seen the
mechanism that created a consensus and
yet your mind still thinks there's wide
agreement when in fact it knows enough
to know that it knows it at best it
knows nothing about how much organic
agreement there actually is
yeah i don't i don't know
if it has a name and if it does have a
name what the name is uh i'm not too up
on uh
all of the fallacies and and their
various names but it does seem like it
warrants one
uh because it is
it isn't it is a psychological error or
maybe it's not a psychological error
it's a it's a failure to recognize uh a
pattern that that should be recognizable
yeah
it is and you know there's one other
place i see a similar thing which is if
you had you know two shampoos and one of
them has a slick advertising campaign
uh with a famous spokesperson or
something like that
uh
you should probably think negatively
about that one um so anyway i guess the
point is why do you know this
basket of pins here are
people purchasing things broadcasting
something downstream of a phony
consensus which is a funny thing to do
of course we don't know how well the
pins sell but the fact that they're
sitting there means that somebody
expected they would yeah
and i saw this just moments really after
i had the reason i was in north portland
was to pick up um a beautiful piece of
art that i had commissioned many months
ago and um
just a small a a small piece of of glass
and uh i had a conversation with the
artist who's lived in portland uh for i
think maybe all of her life but at least
um at least since college and she's
uh you know she's in our age range
uh and
i guess at some level you've been doing
this your entire life but at this point
i
just start talking to people as if
they're going to be reasonable
rather than
being careful about not saying things
about which the forced consensus would
uh seem to make us believe that
everyone probably disagrees with me and
therefore you better not go there
and this lovely artist this lovely woman
just opened right up and she said oh yes
i you know i i love portland and i want
to stay but i can't i don't know if we
can it's it's such it's such a mess here
and i you know
and you know to use
uh the language that i
we've been using for a long time but i
feel uh michael schellenberger really
formalized in his in his book san
francisco and presumably elsewhere
simon sico yes the book san francisco i
can never say it um
is
we have had our compassion weaponized
against us right we are told
oh if you if if you don't basically
allow those people to have terrible
terrible lives on the street in front of
you then you are being uncompassionate
to them
and no that's actually not compassionate
any more than it is uh compassionate to
let a child cut themselves or starve
themselves
or believe that they are a different sex
than they are and therefore need to
start to medically transition uh none of
these things are the compassionate the
compassionate thing to do
so let's
let's hold on back to your point though
your point was that um you open up to
people and you tell them
that you're actually not part of the
consensus and
at least in my experience it's actually
rare that anybody actually pushes back
on behalf of the consensus it's like
there's this thin veneer of like we all
agree on that and then you say well
actually i don't people don't get me
neither you know so you know no doubt
there are people with whom that wouldn't
work but i think the question is how
tiny a minority is that yes how tiny a
minority is it who appears to be driving
uh
culture and policy at a increasingly
global level for all the rest of us on
behalf of not even them but even if they
think it's for them and even if it is
for some tiny portion of them sorry no
tyranny of a tiny minority
not okay and in part it's being allowed
to happen because we are being told that
it's a majority but
let's go to the next uh photo here zach
this is just so this is again north
portland uh portland
it's sort of like douglas adams
hitchhiker's guide to the uh youth
galaxy trilogy which is actually four is
it now five books no he's been dead
forever but um it turned into five books
a five buck trilogy uh north portland
has four quadrants of which there are
has quadrants of which there are five uh
that's which i don't i don't know why
and north portland is the fifth outlier
one that's a wedge because otherwise
it's northwest southwest northeast
southeast anyway those of you who don't
live here don't care but i don't know i
don't know why that is anyway north
portland um in some ways is a is an
epicenter of the
everyone agrees right and if you don't
what the hell are you doing here
so this is one of many walls that i
walked past with a chaos of of posters
it's mostly not uh it's mostly not
tagged live it's mostly not graffiti but
posters that have been put up
in
in sort of just a i don't know there's a
better word than chaos and some of the
sentiments there
make some sense and some of them don't
some of them are incoherent to me and
presumably coherent to someone but this
this is
what is passing at semolo for street art
in north portland and near there next
photograph zachary
uh is this storefront with erected above
at what looks like a billboard but i
think i think that this apparent
billboard which reads for those of you
just listing abolish police
is actually just a privately privately
owned and erected by this by the
storefront so yes abolish police is
still
still
being advocated for even as uh
portland's homicide rate skyrocketed
uh property damage property crimes
skyrocketed homeless
homelessness and chaos ensuing has
skyrocketed although that was already
quite high in the wake of the move in
the summer of 2020 to defund the police
and unfortunately to some degree the
police were defended and of course many
good police also left the force and many
who were somewhat near retirement but
weren't immediately going to do so left
because who wants to work in an
environment like this
yes and actually separately
i've been noticing in the last couple of
weeks
police engaged in normal police behavior
and i'm wondering whether this is
in some way organically true or whether
or not the police responded to the
population signing on to a phony
consensus about abolish defund all cops
or bastards i had the sense that cops
had stopped enforcing
anything but the most extreme uh
laws
and even then doing so with such a delay
that things like our homicide rate
skyrocketed
um so i guess there's a question and i
don't know what to think about it
because
as we said
uh very forcefully at the time
demonizing the police is insane right
there's obviously bad policing but if
you think the net effect of police is to
increase crime you have you have lost
the plot yes right
and you know you can't measure the crime
that doesn't happen because the police
do come when you call right right you
just can't measure it so
um in any case yes it was insane for us
to allow the demonization of the police
and it is not surprising that the police
might choose to allow us to discover
something of
what happens when they don't enforce the
law because how long are you going to
put up with being called
bastards and being accused of being a
net source of crime and being told that
you might be killed on site
right and actually having uh you know
your your murder openly advocated on
walls across the city
so anyway
i obviously can't defend the police not
enforcing the law but it's not hard to
imagine how they might become reluctant
yeah um so
anyway yes i'm a little surprised to see
that uh
that sign on this business
now because obviously a lot of people
have had time to recognize what happens
as you even begin to move in the
direction of abolishing or defunding the
police
and uh basically it's exactly what you'd
expect it's you know it's warlordism but
it may become a little more clear uh
once i'm gonna zoom in in the next
couple of pictures on you can see flyers
in the window of this store front which
is not open and i couldn't exactly tell
what it was and the lighting was bad so
these next pictures aren't too too great
but next next photo if you will one of
the flyers in the window there reads
again sorry about the reflection honor
trans-immigrant lives
which okay honor honor all lives you
know not to trigger all those people out
there like what do you mean you can't
talk about all lives until the people
who are least privileged
and most historically undervalued are
protected
i don't agree with that but i get that
sentiment but it is this adding
trans
into other discussions
which is something we talked about two
summers ago during the during the summer
of george floyd during the summer of
over 100 consecutive days of protests
which turned into a hundred consecutive
nights of violent riots in the city of
portland
where trans just gets entered into every
discussion and then becomes central and
you might argue right now it's pride
month it's just that no sorry no that's
not what's going on so honor trans
immigrant lives that's
just odd right like what a what a niche
group that is what are we talking about
how many people were talking about okay
so next one next flyer
is
uh
protect black trans sex workers
also very niche
also adding another group
to the mix sex workers which
uh is yes more more susceptible to
violence
in their lives
and
also
not just work as people involved in
in advocating for quote unquote sex work
insist it is different
and it should not be treated the same
way as a secretarial job for instance
but i will also point out the you know
amazing irony of the security alert for
our video surveillance
right next to
the protect black trans sex workers
poster which is on the storefront which
is has across the top a faux billboard
that reads abolish police
so presumably they've got some private
company or you know or it's or it's not
for real right but they've but if if
this is for real at all if they really
do have it's actually says 24 hours some
per hour i just
they just didn't catch it on the screen
here 24-hour video surveillance if
they've got anyone showing up then we're
talking about private security then
we're talking about mercenaries
basically and this is what we want we
you know we we prefer our protection to
be in the hands of only those who can
afford it like used to be for for
instance the fire department
and uh only to be
only to happen when you happen to have
thought in advance about whether or not
you had a risk as opposed to
having you know fixing the problems with
um police forces which police forces
recognize have existed
you know there there are there are power
problems there have been racial problems
all of this is true
but they exist for all of us they exist
to serve all of us they are funded by
all of our tax dollars and they are
supposed to be working on all of our
behalf unlike private security which to
have to have that security alert 24-hour
video surveillance posted on the same
building that says abolish police
strikes me as a particular kind of 21st
century confusion that i didn't see
coming
yes on the other hand
it seems to me that the
the poster that has been put in the
window here
like the others is
effectively
bait
the answer is what are your choices with
respect to such a poster
would you like to spell out
what your objection is to protecting uh
black trans sex workers do you believe
that black transsex workers are not
vulnerable are they not human are they
right is it is it that they're black
that makes you indifferent right so the
point is
one has to have a very
steady
mind in order to figure out how
to correctly raise the objection and it
still isn't safe to do right right and
so the real point is this is kind it's
visual sophistry the point is it's an
invitation to a discussion in which at
best you will survive
right
likely you will trip over one of several
booby traps in
the in the visual presentation and the
claim and you know i never saw anything
this
extreme in terms of the the
nichification of the groups about whom
we are supposed to care yeah
until the last few years but before ever
green blue when we were still at
evergreen and there was the you know
there was the black lives matter
nichification of progressive stack you
know demographics that you were supposed
to care about stuff
when i would see
things about oh you know it's it's the
it's the black femmes on campus who are
most at risk like are there two of you
yeah like like seriously at risk and at
risk of what like no you're not at risk
and there's two of you and you're just
the two people who have identified
yourself as this like you're just making
stuff up but also it felt like
okay whatever like i'm not i'm just i'm
not gonna go there because
because it's going to be too easy to
paint me or anyone who raises objections
to their for-hitting black femmes right
or
uh black trans sex workers or trans
immigrants like no that's different
and and i think and i think you have
actually nailed it that this
is visual sophistry this is design
sophistry this is pr this is software
streams pr
and marketing
and
even those of us who can see it for what
it is largely you know we have to choose
our battles and we say oh okay
fine go ahead and fight your fight for
black tram sex workers and i guess at
some level i'm saying
this is this is beyond absurd
these you know i don't i don't know
exactly how to make the analogy work but
this emperor is long since naked
and we need to stop pretending that the
people who put abolish police and
protect black trans sex workers are
actually interested in a society that
treats all human beings equally because
they don't well that's the thing about
the sophistry though and this is why i
um
keep
pointing to this particular uniting
thread is that
the problem is actually in
the burden and threshold of proof
that by leveling
certain arguments as if they are
credible arguments the basic point is
well
you would have to beat this argument
in order to uh to prevent the natural
conclusion from arising we should be
investing in protecting black trans sex
workers well that is not a slam dunk
because the question is
really one of what is the you know
how do we protect people who are
vulnerable best
right
how do we distribute the resources for
that and it is very easy to become
obsessed with certain things and you
know for example
if we look at something like
mass shootings which are obviously
catastrophic
but
our focus on mass shootings is bizarre
in light of our failure to focus on for
example yatrogenic harm from medical
errors right because what is more likely
to kill you that's a runaway win for
yatrogenic harm and yet it's not
compelling because you don't see it
happen in the same way so you know the
point is you
we have to figure out how to say
i'm actually not required to meet that
argument right the burden is on you to
establish that this is a reasonable
standard by which to apportion limited
resources yeah right from the point of
view of minimizing harm or maximizing
good or whatever it is that you're
trying to do but the burden's on you
it's not that as long as you can phrase
an argument that it's gonna take me five
minutes to explain what's wrong with it
right you win unless i invest the five
minutes and you're compelled that's not
how it works and
by making a claim that we need to do x
what have you just undone of the other
things that society had already agreed
we need to do
and
too often we aren't shown the thing that
we're now going to lose
and then when you do raise the thing
that you're going to lose you say ah see
again you're you're not caring about
protecting black trans sex workers so i
would say you know forget about the
trans part of this forget about the
black part of this i don't care if
you're trans or not and i don't get your
races
one thing that i care more about than
protecting sex workers is protecting
children
children
are they're a lot more of them and
they're inherently innocent
and
i want to protect children from being
exposed to sex workers and sex work and
that incidentally includes things like
uh and this is a broad a broad
definition of sex work and there will be
some who can legitimately disagree here
but that includes things like burlesque
and drag shows and peep shows okay which
many drag shows turn into
children should not be exposed to this
this is something we had all agreed on
until yesterday
sex workers rights
to perform burlesque or whatever it is
that they want to call it or to engage
in quote unquote sex work and i don't
like that term either
uh cannot infringe if
we can put aside do they have that right
claim that they do absurd that they do
for the moment that right cannot
infringe on the more important and more
fundamental right of children to never
be exposed to that thing and again just
as we made a point of never talking to
our children about suicide until they
were
old enough and we're not gonna talk here
about like what that means and people
will disagree about exactly what that
boundary is
but we protected them avidly from any
conversation any exposure to the concept
and some people won't be able to because
their children unfortunately know it all
too close but most children do not there
is no reason to put that into a child's
mind similarly there is no reason to put
into a child's mind the idea
that people are exchanging sexual favors
for money
to put sexual activity into their minds
at all to put into their minds that they
could become you know that the little
girl could become like daddy when she
grows up no she cannot
so again the question is
the argument is a feeble one on the
other side
it is sophistry so the point is feeble
as it may be it's going to take some
work to explain exactly what's wrong
with it and what's wrong with it in the
case of uh burlesque and
things related to it and children is
that
the upside of exposing children to this
is essentially zero and the potential
downside is massive so the point is
given that it this does not require an
argument from those of us who would like
to protect children the point is it's a
slam dunk even if the other side was
right what's the value in it yeah so
there's so much in this world there's so
much
that we were unable to
expose our children to
there's just so many opportunities
there's so much nature there's so much
art there's so much music there's so
much literature there's so much there's
so many things
and you know gardens and just so many
things that children can spend their
time
marveling at the wonders of the world
and
there's no way that sex shows should be
on that list
and uh yeah so but
this brings a number of things together
because the point is a we all agreed on
this until five minutes ago for a reason
one it's obvious
so two
is it incumbent on us to explain why
it can't suddenly become okay right even
if you thought it might be okay you
wouldn't assume it was okay in light of
the risk right
but
the coerced consensus around this means
that it's actually happening we've gone
from everybody agreeing that it would be
wrong to have a child at a burlesque
show
to a state in which it is now presumed
to be okay and if you say hey wait still
not okay then the point is oh what kind
of bigot are you yeah you live in the
dark ages man right and so
you know
the problem is sophist sophistry
is um
not a well understood concept by most
people and so saying it is sophistry
works with an audience that's been uh
brought up to speed or knows the term
already
what do we do
so that we can
put the burden of proof back where it
naturally goes in argument after
argument right
because that's what's happened is by by
leveling these softest arguments they
have flipped the burden of proof and
it's very effective right it doesn't
make their point any better but it makes
it more powerful and that that's the
thing that we have to uh figure out how
to repel but i don't know what to i
don't know what to do because again and
again it's like i can see the flaw in
that argument and i'm gonna i'm gonna
explain it and it's like cool that i can
explain it but the really important
point is i don't have to right none of
us have to these are not good arguments
even if explaining why they're bad takes
five minutes right rights yes absolutely
let's go to the last slide zach
a picture from yesterday in north
portland
this is a little unclear it's it's a
telephone pole that has you know
probably years worth of posters attached
to it the most modern one being pride
brunch
you can't see that very clearly but the
four performers all appear to be uh in
drag and so
i i thought okay pride brunch
cool i guess you know pride pride month
has never mean anything i mean mean
meant
yeah that's the term that's the term uh
anything in particular to me but it's
you know it's in the existence as long
as i can remember and okay
uh click through though you know go to
that
uh
whatever that code is called yeah the qr
code and zach if you would show my
screen briefly
the pride brunch is actually it's
actually happening hey it's happening
almost right now the door's open in
eight minutes so if you're in portland
and would rather be here actually no
it's sold out sorry can't go
um
but you read read the fine print and it
really is quite fine isn't it uh here
a little bit bigger
and find that it's an all-star cast for
a drag queen brunch
well that's different all star casts for
drag queen brunch i thought it was a
pride brunch nope it's a drag queen
brunch
i'm sorry
not the same yep so
i want to protect children before i want
to protect sex workers i want to protect
women before i want to protect
trans men's rights to be trans women
sorry rights to be in the prisons of the
gender that they identify as and i want
to protect
gay people
for to have their you know have spaces
and actually have some place to honor
themselves and what it is that their
unique situation in life goes through
rather than having everything in pride
much be pride munch
wow pride month being replaced with drag
and trans
and it seems like it's there everywhere
and you know here of course we have
uh where are your pride colors and come
celebrate what makes the
lgbtqia plus community so dang special
yeah this is a topic much better covered
uh
by others i'm thinking in particular of
uh katie herzog and mike solana two two
of my uh oh and douglas murray of course
all make
related points very very well but
there is something
you and i are old enough to remember um
when
being gay was
far more of a big deal than it is now
and one of the things that those who
truly did harbor bigotry about
homosexuals
used to say
was that you know that this was somehow
about recruiting children
now the problem is
that
that's not what
gays were doing but there is that
element here and of course we can now
the community has got all these other
letters associated with it right and
that uh
i
i'm struggling for terminology that i
shouldn't be struggling for but um you
know garden variety gay folks
um
are now um
being challenged by their supposed
community
right for simply being gay that's
because that has successfully been
understood as a normal phenomenon the
point is there's this other
um element that is now pushing really
fringe dangerous stuff involving
children and you know one has to feel
tremendous sympathy for for homosexuals
who did finally finally win their place
in society um you know that was a long
ugly terrible struggle and now it's like
you know they they enjoyed five minutes
of being welcomed in polite society
before they're now being challenged by
their supposedly own community that's
it's quite the predicament no and then
the same argument can be made for the
much larger community you know
population of people that are women uh
who
you know have had been
more fully
uh empowered with legal rights for
somewhat longer than homosexuals had in
most maybe all countries um but are
seeing our
rights eroded by the same
fringe community and you know and
children is a little bit of a different
situation because you know people have
been trying to protect children for
forever and other people have been
trying to exploit children forever
but the the new thing there is that
suddenly it has become the compassionate
the liberal thing to do to encourage
children to be exposed to adult human
beings
sex perversions
no not compassionate not liberal that's
on you for falling prey to some really
insane ideology and i recommend that you
think it through like just put those
words through a filter and like yeah
actually i don't think i want my kid
exposed to that yeah i don't think i
want anyone's kids exposed to that
right um and i will just
at the tail end of this point out i've
started to hear this week
maybe we've heard it before but about
the question of of reparations for trans
people right
oh yeah this is this is a great one
because of course okay yeah look
reasonable people can disagree and i
think actually there is a very natural
conversation to be had around
reparations for american blacks right
there is a long history of oppression it
is handed down through a lineage and the
question is how do we write that wrong
once and for all and you know very smart
very carefully considered
people with very carefully considered
opinions do actually disagree on this
front and i have heard arguments on both
sides that are compelling to me right
and in fact i will say my position is an
intermediate one which is i think
reparations are justified but cash
reparations are not going to work and
they create a bunch of new problems that
will make things worse so the question
is for example how do we invest in
communities to finally level the playing
field right without
creating an excuse for civilization to
move on from the genuine harm that is a
part of our history yeah so anyway there
is plenty of room for rational arguments
the problem is
it's you know it's just like all of
these other things right gays win
legitimacy in society and then a bunch
of people follow them through the door
with arguments that they claim are the
same argument just the next phase of it
but it's not the same argument women
gain the ability to uh to compete
against each other without having to
compete against men and then a bunch of
guys follow them through the door you
know um
and
start beating them in the pool and
bicycling in every other way well and
it's not a metaphor if you take it out
of sport and take it into actual safe
spaces oh yeah domestic abuse right
right right and such and like oh who
followed me to the door that's not a
woman right no doesn't belong here no
100 but the point is okay the
reparations argument is on the table
well it's about time it's on the table
right whatever the right uh
resolution of that question is but the
argument does not apply this is again
sophistry right because trans people are
not a lineage so the point is the idea
that if you are trans you know in june
of 2022 that you are therefore suffering
the weight of oppression that has
followed you through history no you
probably became trans in 2022 or maybe
it was 2021 but but the point is the
whole argument doesn't follow and yet
again it's like yeah you know i'm not
wrong because it takes a little
explaining to get there
now this this is critical i mean we've
talked about this not with regard to
trans before with regard to how sex and
race are different in fact we talked
about a little bit last week
that sexism is real and racism is real
but they have some very important
distinctions between them
and one of one of the ways to understand
it is exactly as you just pointed out
sex is not a lineage
everyone has an equal number of male and
female
ancestors and there's going to be people
who say i don't know what i'm talking
about well you're thinking at the
population level because you've heard
that there are more
uh you know there
there are fewer males who have
successfully reproduced in the past
which is true so the population level
not all men reproduce but almost all
women do but at an individual level
you've got a mom and a dad and so did
both of your mom and dad and so did on
on back forever like everyone had one
mother one father therefore an equal
number of male and female
ancestors
and um that means that
woman is not a lineage
you've got an equal number of woman
ancestors whether or not you're a woman
or man as you do man ancestors whereas
race which is messy because again as we
talked about last week it's reticulate
and no you know no races are are pure
and i say that's a gross word to use
here and i put it in quotes and
everything um but we're all you know
interbreeding all the time and so you
know it's
it's it's a very messy concept uh in
humans but there is a lineage component
and because it bears an external
phenotypic marker it has been used to
abuse and keep down whole groups of
people obviously we all know this even
the racist among us know this right um
that you know there is a history of
actual you know slavery and
institutionalized racism and things like
this um so but trans even more than sex
precisely because you are born a
particular sex and therefore at least
through your own developmental history
you may if you're born in a particular
moment under a particular situation bear
the brunt of like [ __ ] sorry but like i
was born female and that wasn't good
here and therefore a lot of bad things
happen to me that wouldn't have happened
if i were male
trans
for most people who are calling
themselves trans now is a hat it's a
thing they're putting on and so at the
moment that they decide now i am and oh
i'm sure i was all along maybe in some
cases yes
for some very rare cases yes
but for most of you to put it on and
they say now gimme now i'm gonna get
what what i'm due because of all the
past depression that i wasn't even
around for nope that's not how it works
yeah i was gonna say um
what i said could sound callous about
most uh of these folks maybe became
trans in 2021 or 2022 but the point is
actually that's the problem right trans
is a real thing and many people have
been trans
uh you know for much of their lives but
the point is the contagious part of this
the socially contagious part is a
different phenomenon which is what many
of us including people like uh blair
white and buck angel are trying to say
there's there's trans activism which is
a contagious movement and there is
trans which is a much smaller group of
people who genuinely wrestle with things
still not a lineage yeah right
still not a lineage that's right but
nonetheless those are two two different
categories so um
there's a big thing that i want to do
this week prompted by some news that
reuters put out in which they say
gender affirming guidance for
prepubescent children is non-invasive
and includes professional support
experts say
and i started thinking about who are
these insane experts who say such a
thing and it turns out it's wpath the
world professional association for
transgender health
and i spent a lot of time looking into
their document their their uh standards
of care for the health of transsexual
transgender and gender non-conforming
people uh i think given
that you have a lot of stuff you won't
still want to talk about and that we're
under some time pressure this week i'm
going to save this i definitely want to
come back to i i have some i have some
dismantling of
wpath's
standards for of care for the health of
transsexual transgender and gender
non-conforming people
uh but i don't want to have it be rushed
i do want to say two more things before
we segue into what you're what you're
going to do though one of them is and
again i'll return to this when i do when
we do return to this with more time
the document is literally called once
again standards of care for the health
of transsexual transgender and gender
non-conforming people
it's hard for me to do this without
getting either angry or just laughing
three categories standards of care we're
talking about medical care transsexuals
transgender people
and gender non-conforming people
yeah tomboy medicine
there are no human transsexuals that's
not possible okay that's not a possible
state for humans humans cannot be
um hermaphrodites sequential
hermaphrodites some fish can
we're not we're not fishing that way
we're some some actinopterygians okay
you can look it up if you can spell it
and go find whatever fish but we're not
reef fish yeah some reef fish can a few
other a few other non-refish i think can
but there are no human transsexuals so
that's not that's an empty category
uh there are human transgender people
and uh
when i say that when brett says that
what we mean usually is what uh many of
the professionals are meaning when they
say transsexual and then they're lumping
all of this sort of
uh
kind of gender dysphoric uh but i'm not
going to fully transition with all of
the tools at my disposal into
transgender
but i'm going to leave that as a
category that is worthy of consideration
with regard to what kinds of treatment
and care
we should be delivering to these people
the third category for which wpath has
written an incredibly long document
which i will dismantle another time
which they say warrants standards of
care gender non-conforming people
gender non-conforming people are people
who don't entirely ascribe to the
expectations of the sex to which they
were born not assigned
for their culture
now in
1980
to pick a date far enough in the past
for it to be i'm certain this is true
and yet not so modern that it had begun
to be dismantled already by 1980 in the
united states at least and i think in
all of the weird world although weird
wasn't an acronym yet coined
it was well understood
that
women who desired to work full-time in
the workforce and maybe weren't that
interested in having a family were not
less of a woman
because of that
and that men who were interested in
going to caregiving professions
were not
less of a man for doing that
those people are gender non-conforming
as i was gender non-conforming as a
child and and still in many ways
m
i have i have many characteristics
that are more male typical than female
typical and that's what gender is gender
is the behavioral manifestations the
personality manifestations the softer
manifestations of sex which is hardware
and if you are
a
clownfish
your gender aka your sex role 100
follows from your sex and when your sex
changes so does your gender known as sex
role in clownfish and there's no
negotiation there's no ambiguity in
humans of course there is we're so much
more software we've got so much more
going on and so much of the sex role in
the first place the gender was a
negotiated overlay in the first place we
don't change color when we change sex
unlike reef fish who do that
we don't change our
um i mean we don't we don't we don't
change checks we don't change color when
a woman decides that she wants to be an
aviation mechanic
you don't now have badges you know maybe
you put on overalls
right because it's appropriate to the
job and maybe you put on overalls
because you feel more comfortable in it
and because it feels like an expression
of who you want to be
doesn't make you male
and it doesn't change the underlying
reality so the idea that gender
non-conforming people require care
require medical care that's a sign that
we are going backwards requires special
medical care right
that the idea that that those of us who
don't fall in line with the cultural
expectations of how we should act
because of the sex that we were born to
are lumped in with transsexual and which
doesn't exist in transgender which does
exist people
is itself a sign of intentional
confusion and regression back towards a
day when women actually weren't able to
do as many things as we do now
so that's that's the little rant that
will be included in a larger analysis of
this document which
is this document was written by the
people who are the experts that reuters
is now using as their fact check when
they say gender referring guidance for
pre-pubescent children is non-invasive
and includes professional support
experts say one more little teaser one
of the things they say in this document
is
i find it
puberty blockers are fully reversible
interventions
so i'll just
i'll just leave it there no wrong
patently false
everyone who's given any thought knows
this and if you think that you're a
healthcare worker and you still think
that puberty blockers are fully
reversible you have no business doing
the job that you're doing you are a
danger to your clients
all right
they are gender sophists we have to
remember that right one does very
tempted to explain everything that's
wrong on the other hand it's cool to
explain it but it's not a requirement
because it's obviously wrong
bad news for these gender sophists joan
of arc was not a man
not a man not a man not a man nope not a
man um
the other thing which is just sort of a
a bigger observation not about wpath i'm
off my
off that soapbox for the moment uh but
walking around north portland as i was
taking those few pictures and more
and interacting with people
um
where even there it was possible to get
smiles from people on the street not as
easy as in other parts of portland but
it was possible
my sense was i i just had this image of
and maybe it's at times maybe it's
portland maybe it's the west coast we
might sell the united states maybe it's
the whole world
like we're on some giant giant lake
that's
pretty flat at the edges
and it's really cold out and it's frozen
and we're all standing on this lake
and we're just trying to exist and not
freeze to death by falling into the
water below
and there's yahoos coming from all the
sides
and they're coming onto parts of the
lake
that we're on and they start jumping up
and down
and
i feel like i'm hearing the ice cracking
from deep in the lake and it's just
radiating up that sound for anyone who's
been
on a lake in winter when
maybe it wasn't quite completely frozen
and you begin to hear the ice
as it cracks and you think i gotta get
out of here i gotta move this is no
longer safe and if it's just you
and you weren't being too much of a
yahoo yourself getting to where you are
you can probably get out of there but
there's other people
on whom you have no ability to tell them
stop doing that stop jumping up and down
on the ice you're going to break it and
then all of us are doomed
it's really hard to save yourself so
i i now since since yesterday walking
around north portland where it's
endlessly raining but it's not that cold
so i'm not sure where this
image of this vast frozen lake came from
but i feel like
everyone needs to recognize our shared
fate here we are all human beings on
this finite beautiful planet and we are
putting so much at risk with this
sophistry
yes i i can't help but
see the sophists on the lake as
um throwing sledgehammers and breaking
out jackhammers and uh
i'm just seeing the people and i'm
seeing them jumping up and down fiercely
like for me we start adding machines and
tools like that's a very male approach
right but um and you know maybe maybe
that's just
you know you can have that image but for
me it's actually just this endless lake
with people
and sure they have clothes on but it's
really just frozen water and people
and
because edges are less frozen and more
shallow
or you know because there's different
depths and there's different places
where this the currents are stronger
underneath and you can't tell once it's
frozen on top but where the current is
stronger the ice will be weaker
and so jump there but don't know what's
underneath what you are putting at risk
by jumping there
and you have no idea what you're putting
at risk yeah you know no idea and it's
not they're not entitled to put other
people's stuff at risk which is yeah
your point they're putting us all at
risk yeah okay
all right um so i'm going to start in an
odd place here
i'm just going to make a claim and then
you can think about it on your own and
understand what it implies
let's say that you were standing in a
forest let's make it a really diverse
one you know the amazon
every creature that you see
is the result of a three and a half
billion year winning streak of
reproduction and for almost every
creature that you see that winning
streak is about to come to an end right
that's just statistically true most
creatures are dead ends very soon but by
virtue of their having arrived here we
know that they have never lost till this
point right they've arrived
that's why evolution is so effective
right it's effective because of that
massive edit each and every generation
that eliminates all but the ones in
which the best characteristics and good
luck have come together and gotten them
one more time through this intense
bottleneck right
so evolution is very powerful process
for that reason because of the constant
massive editing
economics isn't quite that effective but
it has the same characteristic now when
we say that a creature
fits into a niche
what do we mean
what we mean is that there is some
abstraction some way to exist
that it that is there and creatures by
exploring that space right those
creatures with a little bit more of this
a little bit longer limbs right a little
bit
more acute eyes whatever it is
longer snouts whatever it happens to be
the creatures come to fit that niche in
the same way that a liquid comes to fit
the shape of whatever container you put
it in so the point is
evolution whether it's economic or
biotic
explores the shapes of containers and it
tells us what the shape of the container
is by what works what sticks what we see
there
and all right
the reason this comes up
is i was for the third time in
a
short number of weeks
confronted by
the system for covid testing that one
has to engage in to participate in
certain activities these are tests that
you source within a certain number of
hours before you get on a plane or
attend an event or in cases in portland
some places you would have to do it to
go to a restaurant if you can't prove
you're vaccinated
most recently to get
toby admission to camp yes toby
admission to camp um
we have also done it
i've now done it in three countries i've
done it in the u.s a couple of times
i've done it in britain and we've done
it in the bahamas
each time the experience is the same
it's
very
um
uh bureaucratic
but surprisingly efficient strange
talking about covet testing makes us
both cough
yeah it does um but but the point is um
one goes in and one fears that somebody
is going to jam a snot a swab way up
into your sinuses but in fact it's not
it doesn't go in so deep in fact they'll
hand you the swab and you do it yourself
and
it does raise a question i mean for one
thing
you and i have both had coveted i have
yet to successfully test positive we
know that we've had kovid because for
example you and i one of us gave it to
the other and then you lost your sense
of smell i had an osmium right which is
really the good test yeah um but you
know at least for the antigen tests it
didn't come up positive for us so that's
interesting
lab work is difficult these tests are
not particularly good in fact one of the
things that we don't know is how good
these tests even are and good at what
are they how good are they for one
variant to the next right we don't know
these questions
but
the point that i want to make is that
there is a niche now for a service
that service ostensibly is about testing
for covid and in principle this is a
good idea
covett is a dangerous disease right much
more dangerous than the case fatality
rate would have you understand
trying to control its spread is a good
idea knowing who has it is a good
element in a program to control its
spread from one part of the country to
the next from one country to the next it
makes sense but what has emerged in this
niche
is a racket
right a low quality testing service that
is very expensive right the tests in the
us cost 300 bucks a pop if you need them
on short notice and you do need them on
short notice because people say you need
it within
48 hours of travel and in principle
that's a good idea right so that you
have a good sense that everybody who
arrives has just tested negative and
therefore is likely to remain negative
you know principle is a great idea but
the point is what you've got
is something that is exploring the
dimensions
of this niche and one of the elements of
this niche is that it is going to reward
poor testing
rather than high quality testing
if you have covid you test negative you
go to whatever the event is and it turns
into a super spreader event what are the
chances that anybody is tracking which
lab failed to detect your token
right so the point is the incentive yeah
on top of the event now having a super
spreader event to mitigate the
downstream effects of they're going to
go and do due diligence on every single
person's covet test no they're not right
they're not
exist but somebody would have you'd have
to set up something like an agency
in order to figure out which labs were
more likely to miss active covid right
you would need a series of super
spreader events and then you would chase
them back to potentially organizations
that had run the test badly to protocols
that didn't work right but no such
oversight appears to exist anywhere and
so the point is and without which i mean
this is where you're going without which
it's it's pure theater it's worse than
pure theater because what it does is it
inhabits the
space a good expensive theater though
it's lucrative lucrative yeah it's
expensive for us
fills the space in the environment where
a good testing program would go so if
you had the idea of well you know what
it would be really great if we had good
labs that gave good tests especially hey
maybe even at a good price right well
the question is
economically speaking which of these
things is going to win that niche
right is it the one where you're likely
to get an a test that says you're
covered positive is it the very
sensitive high quality test that's going
to win out probably not because if
you're in the position of getting one of
these tests then you know you're rooting
for a negative result right you want to
go to the thing you want to get on the
airplane you want to go to the place
that you've got reservations you don't
want a positive test and so the point is
there is competition to deliver you an
answer that you want that is going to
increase the number of super spreader
events it's going to increase the amount
of covid the difficulty of controlling
it the number of variants that are going
to circulate around the world and if you
tried to do it right you would lose in
competition with these folks who have
that niche filled right and so yeah this
is a place where market forces fail us
well let's put it this way they don't
have to well they have right because
all of the testing centers um within a
particular geographic area are in direct
competition with one another and so that
that testing center which had access to
or did due diligence on actually doing a
more reliable providing more reliable
test results
and thus providing fewer false negatives
would lose in competition would lose in
competition and there's a question about
how far up the scales in other words the
system that created the niche how
interested in it is it in controlling
covid versus appearing to be very active
in controlling kovid without bothering
and you know it bears mention that at
least one part of this system is making
so much money from covid that it has a
perverse incentive right is the moral
decency of the people in charge of
pharma so good that it overwhelms their
fiscal benefit from uh not controlling
covet and delivering
lousy remedies that are expensive and
mandated and paid for by government
right
i don't know maybe they're exceedingly
good people but all of them
all of them right or you know even if
you even if you imagine that that's true
all right so you have multiple companies
let's say nine out of ten are run by
exceedingly moral people who just would
never think about somehow their boards
are cool with this their boards are cool
even though it is a violation of their
fiduciary responsibility to their
shareholders but all it takes is the one
company that isn't run by those people
one company that's just simply run by
business people right and that company
will win and then it will take over the
industry so
basic point is hey look you get whatever
the niche is right you you don't expect
when you pour
water into a glass you don't expect it
to inhabit half the glass and leave half
the glass empty it will fill whatever
shape you've given it and the point is
the niches are what they are
the businesses will discover the shape
of the niche those that are better able
to explore and figure out where the
opportunities are that aren't so cool
but nonetheless are lucrative those
businesses will will win out in
competition and so we get these things
so check this out though um i just read
and i
don't think i figured out where it is
before our show here today but i just
read that as of tomorrow as of june 12th
the cdc has declared and i question why
the cdc gets to declare anything
anytime anywhere ever again but like i
just don't think they have the authority
they're not that kind of an agency but
the cdc has declared that as of june 12
people coming to the u.s do not need to
have a negative covet test
which is interesting in light of all of
this
that the u.s is saying yep or i don't
know what the us is saying the cdc is
saying
uh the things changed this is this is no
longer a necessary part of the protocol
right which could mean a lot of
different things it could be you know so
my claim is that the uh kova testing
regime is a racket
right yes the idea is it looks like a
kova testing regime but really it's a
rubber stamping mechanism where you get
you pay 300 bucks for the rubber stamp
um and the chances that they catch uh
you know your active infection are
you know at least lower than they should
be it reminds me of getting research
permits in uh
tropical countries back when back when i
was actively doing
you didn't have to do it as much because
you were often working within um a field
station that took care of a lot of the
logistics for you but i ended up having
to get independent permits
in three different countries in latin
america and madagascar and i mean you
were there for some of the wrangling
with bureaucrats in madagascar you know
i got asked for things like i literally
got asked for a land rover like at that
point i made thirteen thousand dollars a
year like do i look like i have a land
rover
but uh it doesn't hurt to ask doesn't
hurt to ask yeah and you know one day we
were told to come back yet again because
the guy with the rubber stamp was gone
the next day though the guy was there
but the key to the office uh was with
someone else and then like it just went
on and on but anyway that yeah the
rubber stamping uh this this rubber
stamping reminds me of uh incoherent
uh bureaucratic procedures
in very poor countries where local dudes
are just trying to make a buck yes the
problem is in the banana republic's
so-called yeah you can see this right
and the the irony of the power of the
guy with the rubber stamp and the fact
that the guy with the rubber stamp makes
so little money that it would be
impossible if somebody's going to
extract a million dollars of lumber out
of a forest they're not supposed to be
cutting lumber from and the person who
has the rubber stamp makes ten thousand
dollars a year it's not hard to change
that guy's picture enough that he'll
look the other way yeah so if i mean
that that's that at least when i was
working in madagascar that that number
would have been way lower yeah yeah just
madagascar was so poor like so yes a
land rover was a very big ask
um but i believe in that case i came
back with a bottle of johnny walker and
you know that was that was good that was
sufficient yeah so um but i wanted to
point to a
shinier fancier version of a closely
related racket because really my point
is you can see it with the covet thing
it's new enough and because we're
interacting with it and learning what
this system looks like it's like oh this
couldn't possibly work right
but
there are other versions of it so one of
them that surprised me during
the uh the covid pandemic
was the discovery of how
the
testing the safety testing of
pharmaceuticals actually works and you
know this is the second time i've
encountered weirdness in that realm the
first time being about telomeres and
mouse evolution which
i will just point out
the story there i don't want to go too
deep because it would take a lot of
explaining but i discovered as a
graduate student
that the mice in the colonies that
supply
our scientific establishment including
our drug safety testing
apparatus those mice had evolved
to the container formed by the market
for laboratory mice and so the point was
look if you're going to breed laboratory
mice you want to produce as many mice
per unit of effort and shelter and food
as you can and that economic pressure to
produce new mice as cheaply as possible
causes breeders to breed young mice and
not old mice and that simple fact
elongated the telomeres of mice and gave
them essentially no protection from
tumors and a essentially infinite
capacity to replace damaged tissue which
selective force that effectively moved
all of the negative effects of all the
drugs that are being tested into later
stages of life right and so the problem
when i discovered that and i discovered
it i predicted it from theory carol
grider then tested it and established
that indeed wild mice did not have long
telomeres which was not obvious at the
time
but the point was when i
found that
i naively believed that what would
happen next is everybody would go
and they would realize that their
science was all polluted by the mice
they had been using and that their drug
safety testing was allowing dangerous
drugs to make it to market and there was
going to be a massive effort to retest
drugs a massive effort to figure out how
this had polluted what we understood
about wound healing and aging and cancer
and everything else and it didn't happen
right now i think
so why why the crickets
one reason i believe
is that
pharma and everything connected to it
realized that it had a mechanism for
making drugs that weren't especially
safe look very safe in fact if you give
a poisonous drug to a mouse that's going
to die of cancer but has an infinite
capacity for repair if the poison isn't
so poisonous that it kills the mouse
outright it may actually make them live
longer because it functions as
chemotherapy since cancer
cells are in the process of always
dividing they are more vulnerable than
regular cells and so that is a result
i've seen several times where a drug
paradoxically makes the animals live
longer and seems super great but the
point is no that won't translate to
humans
nonetheless the point is the mice
adapted to an economic niche
which has very real biological
consequences
the racket i wanted to point to that
isn't particularly visible right the
covid testing racket is visible to us
the one that surprised me
doesn't surprise me in retrospect but
surprised me when i first came to
understand that it existed was that when
we say
pfizer tested its drug
for safety
that's generally not what we mean pfizer
doesn't test the drug what pfizer does
is it contracts
those who specialize in the testing of
drugs to do these tests and the problem
is if you imagine
an outfit that's awesome at testing
drugs and detecting safety signals that
are really important versus one that
sucks at it by design the point is
pfizer has an interest in finding the
one that's going to give it the
equivalent of the rubber stamp and so
there's economic competition even if
pfizer didn't know what it was doing
right to the extent that it gives
business to those that have a protocol
that is most likely to miss safety
signals right then that
it means that pfizer doesn't have its
fingerprints on it it means that its
drug makes it to market because it looks
safer than it is and this is especially
true in the case where you've got
immunity from liability right because
there's no way for the system to come
back and correct it so the evolution of
protocols that don't work
that's what you're going to get if the
shape of the container is such that it
rewards those protocols which we can see
you know how many other places are there
i've now described two right the mouse
version is a third
so how many places has the shape of the
container caused us to put together
something that looks like a scientific
protocol that just doesn't do what it's
supposed to do the two that you
described are the cova testing cova
testing
uh the running of clinical trials to see
how safe and effective
drugs are
where the companies that actually do
that work
are
uh rewarded for pleasing their employers
right or their those who have contracted
them
and then the mouse thing i believe
happened inadvertently i'm yeah all but
certain that nobody planned that but
having discovered that it existed the
incentive to get rid of that and get
mice that could actually tell you when a
drug was dangerous that incentive wasn't
there yeah no i mean certainly in in the
case of the mice by far the most
parsimonious uh explanation for how
those breeding protocols got started was
just simple economics simple like well
in fact that is reflected by the fact
when i found that i went looking because
that has nothing to do with mice or
science what it has to do with is any
protocol in a small it has to be a small
animal it won't work with a large one
because a large one will get cancer and
won't live to reproduce
but in a small enough animal if you
breed for economic efficiency you get
this result and so we've seen it in mice
rats asian hamsters mongolian gerbils
yeah right like there's some hamsters oh
is that mongolian gerbils is that the
same thing i'm agnostic
okay okay um i know there's just there's
a lot of uh anyway doesn't matter um
there are there are a few of these uh
what was the oh you said chickens
chickens yeah so a few rodents and i
guess a bird
that uh should happen where we see uh a
species basically being
designed with some intentionality um to
be a good lab animal
right really it's you know them anytime
the intention is to be a good lab animal
and the the failure is oops complex
systems unintended consequences
um you know antagonistic plyo trophies
which is specifically what you found
with regard to cancer and senescence uh
in uh with regard to telomere length um
which is to say early effects that are
that are good will masculine effects
that are bad yep uh from the same right
same gene i mean you know the basic
point is look it should have been
obvious that your
laboratory colony is an environment
every bit as much as a forest or your
basement you know
or a grain silo right and so whatever
the forces are in that environment is
going to shape that critter because you
haven't done anything to reduce the
tendency of those in the colony that are
better adapted to out-compete those that
are worse adapted so you're going to get
exactly
which you know which we in quotes uh
took advantage of in doing serial
passaging research and you know gain of
function research with regard to yeah
the intention was not
uh to to affect the ferrets there if it
was ferrets or whatever it was but
actually specifically to enhance
functionality and um through
uh monitoring mutations and choosing
which ones we liked in for instance
viruses right so um
we at the vice point as we selected for
well presumably if what we seem to be
able to infer from the nature of sarsko
v2 is the result of serial passaging in
tissues and creatures
presumably in
wuhan
those who ran those experiments were
serially passaging them to create
certain changes but they inevitably
selected for other changes they weren't
even thinking about like adaptation to
the laboratory environment adaptation to
be able to jump evolutionary gaps
because they were running it through
different creatures and tissues
potentially adaptation for very rapid
change yeah rapid rapid variance for
instance yeah yeah
so anyway um i'm not sure how to sum all
this up except to say
that
welcome to complex systems
our environments will cause anything
that has the characteristics of an
evolving
uh lineage or creature to find
the
shape of the niche and inhabit it which
means you need to be you know if you did
want to fix the testing regime if you
did want to fix
pharma's
protocols what you would have to do
is
disincentivize
uh rubber stamp
protocols and incentivize the discovery
of information that actually caused
dangerous drugs not to emerge cause
people with covet not to get on
airplanes
those things and it's not inconceivable
that you could build those incentives
but
the problem is
that um
those with
control tend to be those who are
benefiting from the structure as it
stands and so
you know we saw this week
uh i believe it was um
cdc recommending boosters for
five-year-olds
and in fact
uh the absurdity of this has been
described in public but the basic point
was the whole apparatus is set up to
deliver that answer which is why it
delivered that answer despite the fact
that there's no real medical argument
for it and a very strong argument
against it
um and increasingly
actually even hitting the mainstream
mainstream media we have oh higher rates
of covid in fully boosted people than in
you know so-called fully vaccinated
people which like not boosted
right
no but um look
the system is going to evolve if you
give incentives you know capture will
create an incentive for
those who are supposedly regulated to
generate a the equivalent of a rubber
stamp upstream of them you should not be
surprised when that rubber stamp rubber
stamps things right you should expect
that and what we are dealing with is a
captured system in which the shapes of
these niches are all paradoxical because
the purpose of those niches isn't to
enhance the public's health it's to do
something else right basically you get
regulators whose purpose is to enhance
the well-being of the shareholders of
the corporations that have captured the
regulators right
not surprising
right maddening but not surprising
indeed
well i think that wraps it up for today
uh
we are going to be back next week at our
normal time and we will have a full q a
then so hold your questions until then
uh in the meantime we had we will have a
new episode out with guest uh
brett hosting a guest on tuesday and for
you know for a number of tuesdays to
come and this last week we forgot to say
at the top of the hour the robert malone
episode yes robert new robert malone
episode uh again one of you recorded in
england and i'm not sure what is going
to be this tuesday but another great
conversation that you had in england
right you can find the robert malone one
on spotify the dark horse channel on
spotify yeah because on youtube
you can't handle the truth yeah that's
that's that's pretty much where we are
so
again we encourage you to
if you liked this conversation share it
and come find come find a thriving
discord community by joining either of
our patreons
and
until next time be good to the ones you
love eat good food and get outside be
well everyone
[Music]
[Music]
you